now that school is taking place at home
for some there are some things you might
want to keep in mind on how to keep our
kids
and moms focused and healthy lifestyle
expert sema cohen shares those with us
so glad to be back on las vegas now and
present my top essentials for
back to school all right first off we
have safe sleep
safe sleep is dedicated to providing the
most effective
and practical solution to cell phone
radiation exposure
and features radio frequency id
protection we already know our cell
phones gives off
emf radiation which can lead to health
risks such as cancer and even
infertility
safe sleep has the solution to that the
cell phone and laptop cases use
shielding technology to protect against
99.9
of harmful emf radiation amazing
what i also love about the cell phone
cases that they double
is a stylish wallet while the detachable
style
allows the magnet to back up to your uh
stick to your car mounts and even metal
surfaces
great company terrific products and best
part
they ship worldwide all right honey
bunch
naturals honey bunch natural is proud to
partner
with be informed which is a non-profit
organization
using science-based data-driven
approaches
to improve the health and long-term
sustainability
of honeybees in the united states
all of the proceeds from this bundle
will go directly to the nonprofit
this is safe and fantastic for the whole
family
the bundle includes amazing items such
as this jar of certified
mono floral manuka honey producing new
zealand
a pair of honeycomb is cute with the
wheat candles
and the lemongrass manuka honey sugar
scrub
not only great for the kids by the way
for the mommies
that take care of the students and kids
all right
next sushi sushi is an organic non-gmo
cold pressed juice company that's
located in san diego california
they carry wide variety of juices
kombuchas
and wellness shots which is truly
amazing and fantastic
for the whole family not just for weight
loss
especially to keep an immune system in
top
shape they use cold pressure method
which helps to utilize
more nutrients and more vitamins to each
and every one of the products
sushi constantly donates to organization
school
and all kind of variety of social events
all right
last but not least lux close skincare
this is fantastic for everyone but
especially
college students this wireless led
facial mask is the answer to all of your
skin care needs it's lightweight
it's easy and up for the bell
it has one button with three light
setting
for optimum beauty benefits and each
setting
benefit the skin differently depending
on your beauty needs
the wrap the red one improve collagen
the orange one
helps to flush waste out of your skin
and the blue one
helps with acne acne and even kill
bacteria
i love that the best part that it has
it's easy it's fast
and it all you have to do is use it for
10 minutes of
maximum of 30 minutes a day love that
for everyone
college students and mommies